[Applause]
all right you guys want to take a few
questions sure yeah okay we're gonna
have some questions from the audience
we're gonna have some questions from
twitter um
justin said that when he thought it was
interesting that there are past parents
that we don't often see in the series
kirk and chekhov in this film you guys
find yourselves split up for a time
exploring groups um what was that like
i think it's great you know the first
couple of films were really about at
least for for uh
his relationship with spock and
and that pairing and
in this film these two definitely get a
chance to suss out their relationship
and i get to
tour the
what was it like to spend some time on
spock
uh i think one of the wonderful things
about what we do in this picture is
not only are we honoring the legacy of
all the fantastic uh star trek that has
been before we're actually exploring new
territory and that's what's going to
make it uh so exciting in fact that
the bones and spock get to spend so much
time together and
come to a deeper understanding as it
were i think there's going to be a
real treasure for audiences these are
two characters who are historically
pretty magically opposed so
um you know there's i think also a lot
of humor that comes from that and a lot
of uh like carl said a lot a lot of
depth and
i think they really do finish this film
with a deeper appreciation for when they
started it i was
i don't know if you felt
i like these
are you kidding
darkness
[Applause]
uh we don't have a twitter handle
oh yes kevin cole 14 says what is your
favorite part of filming
part
what is your favorite part of filming
and favorite part about the films in
general
exactly uh i mean
hands down my favorite part of filming
these movies is getting to spend all my
time with these people who are
incredible and you know it keeps being
brought up that we've been doing this
for almost 10 years which is kind of
unfamiliar but it was 2007 when we made
the first movie and uh and it just
you know
we are truly a family to one another and
even though we only get to work together
every three years we stay in touch and
we stay connected and uh and these are
people that will be in my life for the
rest of it and that to me is easily the
best part about about the experience my
friendship
[Applause]
carl was both find himself
they went back would you like to answer
the twitter question sure
the one that he just answered sure
uh i think for me um the really cool
thing about uh us making this picture in
vancouver the other two pictures were
shot here in los angeles
and
all the la based cast had their social
networks but this was like a fraternity
we were all we're staying up we're
forced
there's just so much love
uh so i feel like we uh we all grew a
lot closer and became tighter as a group
and i think that you're going to see it
on the street
i also say i haven't met the bust here
i've heard that
[Applause]
i've heard they're all standing on apple
boxes and all three of these guys are
like giants they're like six one six two
the interest isn't even here so
so
carl does both find himself in any
uncomfortable situations in the song
well yes he finds himself uh
crash landed on a planet with scott
i mean talk about a nightmare scenario
um
yeah
i can't wait to see this is so much fun
um we have a second twitter question
coming up if you could play
another character of star trek films or
shows who would you choose this is from
black mayor's press
i'm gonna play evil kirk
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
zach was it hard for spock and moses to
connect without kirk acting as a buffer
do you think um that now
stop spock and bones are friends
i mean i think they were always friends
in a way i just think they approached
things from very different points of
view and expressed things very
differently um but i think uh i think
the relationship benefited from
the lack of buffering and the fact that
ultimately they're really
needing each other in just in order to
survive you know and the whole movie
really is about all of us finding our
way back to one another and
understanding the power of uh of when we
unify when we're together
and i think for these two characters uh
for audiences who know them and love
them in his harassability and you know
spock's calculated point of view i think
it's going to be really exciting
how much
do you try and listen to the history of
that character and how much do you try
and keep it away to just play and you've
seen for what it is
well actually the first film for me um
was just quite terrifying because uh you
know i'm a lot a long-term fan of star
trek i watched it growing up as a kid
and and then with j.j cassidy in the
movie
i felt that if i wasn't in the movie and
i was going to the cinema
i would want to see something that
some recognizable um semblance of the
character that i grew up in love and i
think that in some way
for all of us that was a challenge was
to
identify what the very essence of those
characters
were and were done so brilliantly well
by um by by the the original actors for
40 odd years to originally to identify
what that instance is and then distill
it into
a younger version of that character and
make it our own and there were some days
where it was quite nerve-wracking um but
i think we were all blessed that in fact
we had such
uh a wonderful helsinki helmsman in the
face of j.j abrams
we had another question from the
audience uh let's see how about over
here yes
the microphone will find its way towards
you
i was just curious
with the death of uh leonardine boy was
it a different vibe on the stone than
the others
yeah
i mean i mean that in the sense that
i've been getting that question a lot
actually what was it like to make this
the first movie without leonard and in a
way i feel like he's actually almost
more a part of this film than he was of
the other two i mean we all
uh were so cognizant of his absence
but i think in the face of that uh we
all helped him in our hearts so much
more fully and uh and i think to the
person on this film uh everybody
showed up to work uh in the spirit of
celebrating his life and his indelible
contributions franchise uh because
honestly i don't really see how it could
have lasted as long as it did without
him
both as an actor
[Applause]
but i feel like you know you'll see he's
he's there he's there in a really
powerful way
[Applause]
that has really become sort of one of
the beating parts of this franchise but
this still really tears that apart um
does being separated change their
relationship
to this him
[Applause]
yeah it's a different you know this is a
different uh film from
kirk the
um department the first two films i
think were really about him dealing with
the shadow of his father you know he
was born on the day that his father
died in that past
pressure on him up to something
that something was something in someone
you didn't really know so
uh the pressure was almost unbearable i
think
um
and then this one i think this terminal
corner was realizing now
as a man who's dealt with those issues
who is he as his own man what is it like
to be the captain of the starship and to
capitalize people without
um
without needing to
burden himself for that legacy and in
that new space that there's a lot of
freedom there thinking about those who
really want to deal
with happy
and then the drama and the sewers and
stuff happened but
cool i think uh is similarly trying to
figure out his path i mean as everybody
remembers from the first film of
uh our reboot you know his planet was
destroyed and i think he's really torn
between his allegiance to
um rebuilding his race
to the federation
and i think that kirk and spock rely on
each other a lot for guidance through
those tough moments they don't really
necessarily have that um in this film so
they both that they've arrived at an
understanding of who they are as
individuals
in an interesting way because they're
not together they don't have each other
yeah
we have another twitter question uh this
movie is more fun or more dark than the
last two again from black mirror as well
[Music]
for me it's always this film
the most fun i have on this film is
having fun and
i think this the tone of this film is
definitely in the vein of what we did in
the first which was kind of fun topic
which has
great pathos and a great storyline some
great action and we we like to have fun
it's not the super broad the marvel is
not meta it's just
fun yeah
and that's right and we all like to make
each other laugh with the simon behind
you know the pen in the background
giving us some good
justin was talking about the incredible
fantasy of getting to direct star trek
being in love with it since he was a kid
and every little boy spends their
childhood running around pretending
their superhero shooting and hiding
behind stuff but you guys actually do
this for a living in movies like this
are there times when you're on set where
you're like
so much fun
yeah i mean
anytime you're on the bridge of the
enterprise and there's 50 million
buttons uh you cannot help but go and
push every single one of them
just to see if something's going to
happen
we also have a lot of other uh
uh which was really fun some some other
big ships and some
little ships that we got
around it was my favorite in this one
was watching
i'll be in the chair i'll see
i'll see john and anton and they are
doing they are doing hand calisthenics
they are swiping [ __ ]
they're finding all sorts of stuff to do
with this thing
you're thinking i'm glad they know what
they're doing
it makes me laugh every time
there is there's a lot
that
is uh chris curry's always learning
something from spock spock has always
been like a big brother to him
what is the relationship like your
relationship with a much younger checkup
well i think i
that's understand it is that um
it's very interesting i've really
thought about it what's nice about our
relationship is that there's a parody
here that two people that are in the
same kind of boat and coming from a
similar spot
and
in this film he uh
[Music]
anton has uh in chekhov there's a
clarity to him he likes his job he likes
um he likes the group he's with
he's not kind of encumbered by the same
bs that the rest of us are
um
there's some there's some very there's
there's a bunny comedy aspect to what we
end up doing that i think people will
enjoy
awesome um and the telephone spoke on
oh there we go
um guys i really appreciate taking time
to answer questions from fans from
twitter from me please give these guys
[Applause]
excellent person scott max
[Applause]
[Music]
all right okay i first discovered star
trek in 1974 the episode was mirror
mirror
[Applause]
until my 13th birthday
on november 21st 1981
you know do the math
okay
but i had a star trek bar mitzvah
[Applause]
endured a transporter
[Music]
and i just got to thank my parents my
family for supporting my obsessions or i
would not be here right now talking to
you and being here to celebrate how cool
that we're all going to prepare
[Applause]
how many of you
really love star trek
[Applause]
how many of you really
know your star trek
thank you very much
[Applause]
and you're all going to raise your hands
do not shout out the answer i will call
on someone someone else with a
microphone will come over to you give me
the microphone that is when you say your
answer do not shout out the answer you
will be disqualified but let's start
with the first question are you ready
and you'll get prizes
first question first question is this on
star trek next generation
is that good all right
just wait just wait
trek the next generation
what was the name
of
dana's cat plus
[Applause]
the name of davis cat is
[Applause]
the second question are you ready
yes
what was in star trek ii
the previous code that lowered the
shield on the
[Applause]
46309
[Applause]
that is
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
right for
the voyage home
what were the names
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's going to get a little harder now
yes this is the cadmium question
in the aggregated series
episode
the counterpart incident
who
was the first captain of the starship
enterprise scott
over here over here
okay okay yes
now
no it's
not oh my god
i wrote the questions
what is captain robert april
[Applause]
thank you all right the last question
ladies and gentlemen last question this
one might be a little copy we're not
playing now thought for everybody
okay
what was the name
of the homeless shelter
run and organized by edith killer
which is the citizen cane of star trek
yes you
it was the sixth street mission that's
wrong oh
that's wrong
okay hey wait this guy this guy yes
that is
correct
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
san diego
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]